Hey,
everyone.
I'm just gonna wait here a minute.
Confirm that I can hear myself.
And I see that YouTube has put my
logo over my face.
How do I remove that?
I confirmed I can hear myself. I don't
need the headphones anymore.
So
I think we do this in channels settings.
I'm sure this is very exciting.
My channel,
customize.
Let's remove.
We'll get there.
In fact, you know what's gonna be a
lot easier?
We're going to just hide you and move
me over here.
Perfect. Okay.
So let's see, where
are we?
So I did a couple of things upfront.
So today we're gonna use this tool I've
been working on called get series to
analyze the commit history of a couple of
open source projects. Today, we are going to
take a look at SwarmKit,
Moby,
and Kubernetes.
Now because
some of these repositories are slightly large, I
thought I would just run git CDs upfront
so that it was not something that we
had to set and wait on. Although we
are still gonna do the import live which
I'm hoping won't be too bad.
Now just
so that everyone is
everyone knows how long this took. The swan
count was the smallest.
That took fifty seconds to run get series.
We can see the command here. So it's
just get series analyze and all I'm gonna
do is
it's just output or redirect all that output
into file.
I do that with SOU then you'll see
what actually gets emitted by get series.
And this is InfluxDB line protocol.
We can just see measurements at the start,
there's some tag information context that we're applying
to the time series
and then we have some field values on
the end. And we'll take into this as
we get into the dashboarding and graphing
segments.
Moby itself took nearly three minutes. So a
little bit larger than swarm cut but not
too bad actually. I believe Mobi has around
40,000
commits and we managed to process all of
that including every delta
in the GET repository
in under three minutes.
Now Kubernetes was obviously the one I had
a little bit of
concern over.
Now it doesn't have that many commits either.
There are
90,000
give or take I believe.
But it does take substantially longer.
So it took thirteen minutes and nine seconds
to generate the lame protocol
for the Kubernetes
repository. Right. And I think the reason for
that is probably just a lot of larger
commits. We'll see that in the graphs as
well. It's
hard to tell. We don't wanna get to
the graphs.
So what I wanna do next is import
all of this into InfluxDB.
So what I've done locally
is I have compiled InfluxDB
on the master branch because
just last week there were a lot of
performance improvements
as particularly around flux
that will hopefully make our queries across
larger timeframes
faster. So we're not watching it spend for
too long.
And of course, because I'm compelling against master,
do have a little bit of concerns that
I may break InfluxDB.
So I have a backup plan if that
happens.
I do have a make fail here with
a couple of just common steps. So if
we need to, we are going to run
the latest beta,
the beta release docker image or container image,
which hopefully is a little bit more stable
than comparing off the master branch.
We have a setup command here which just
allows me to kind of, you know, set
the token that I want to use up
front rather than having to go into the
UI and copy and paste that around,
which means that hopefully I won't have to
modify this telegraph config.
This telegraph config is just gonna scan for
all the line protocol fails inside this directory,
which there are none yet, but we're going
to add them in. It's just saying look,
this is lane lane protocol or Influx format
and we're gonna throw that into our InfluxDB
locally. So that's my next step. Let's get
this data loaded.
I will start with SwarmKit. Should be nice
and fast. We will then pull in Mobi
and then we will maybe just leave Kubernetes
running as we start to look at the
the Mobi and swarm kit graphs.
But we'll see.
Now the biggest
time sync when we import the line protocol
really just comes down to how many entries
we need to write to the server.
And right now I've not checked so we're
gonna do that first.
So I'm just working out of a temporary
directory just now. What I wanna do is
copy
my line protocol files.
So we're gonna grab docker.
Oh, that's git lab.
Docker
swarm kit
swarm LP.
We'll stick that here.
Next we're gonna grab Mobi,
Mobi, Mobi LP
and lastly
we will grab Kubernetes.
If anyone does have questions along the way
I do have the chat open so you
know drop them in.
I think there's around a forty second delay
so just be patient with me if I
don't see it right away. Woah.
My temporary disk.
There's a problem I didn't think I'd hit
right away. Okay. Let's untemp this.
So let's just jump in to get lab
and we'll make a get lost directory.
I'm going to move everything from this temp.
Oh, that's home.
So
I like to work out of a temporary
tree pretty much all the time.
I don't know why. It just because I
have a few Z shell plugins
and those plugins give me pair directory history.
So when I do things like this and
I don't really necessarily want that history jumping
around or just filling up a folder. I
always had to jump into temp. It's just
habit.
Okay. So let's close code,
spin that back up
and we were copying.
Let me just mute myself because I can
actually hear myself come through that. We were
copying
the Kubernetes
line protocol.
Nice. Okay.
So I still need my local
InfluxDB
directory, that's where I'm gonna run it from.
The copy is not fast.
Oh, I do realize that my face is
now
covered up all the commands. Let's show me
that over. I'll
just keep moving him around. That doesn't need
to look professional.
Okay.
Well, thirty seconds to copy that lane protocol.
Alright. So we have
gig.
Ouch.
Okay.
So swarm kit,
we have
what is that? 2,300,000
lines of lane protocol.
Moby, we are sitting at
8,000,000 lines.
And the scary one.
Damn.
43,000,000
lines of line protocol.
Risky.
Alright.
What we're gonna do is run InfluxDB.
No. Let's just browse to this.
I
will need to tell the assets directory.
Maybe I'll just run it through pod man.
Let's
see if I can remember how to do
this. UI
access.
Alright. We're jumping into the backup plan or
the InfluxDB with Podman. Okay.
There we go. Alright. So what we're gonna
see here is to get started screen.
Wants us to create a user authentication cannot
be disabled within FluxDB two.
No. I do not want to set that
up there because
I wanna specify my own token, I don't
need to change my telegraph config.
So what that means is if I jump
over here and just hit refresh on this,
Then I should be able to log in
with user and password one, two, three.
And this is the clean slate. We have
no data, no dashboards.
It's just some internal stuff here. We do
have a bucket that is created in the
setup command.
Let's get some data first. So
we are going to
pop open this telegraph config.
We are gonna grab
mobi
and swarm kit,
enter the lame protocol directory
and I'm going to run telegraph.
Config
telegraph.com.
We wanna run that with debug.
Okay. Just kill it.
So that we know when it's finished.
So it's gonna give me information on well,
first of all, which files are important. Good.
It's just mobi and swarm kit. We can
see the buffer filling up as they're starting
to process those files. I have a very
short flush interval on this. Hopefully just keep
it fast.
What we wanna kind of see now is
just hopefully the buffer will stop filling and
start actually emptying.
But we know we have a substantial set
of metrics here. So let's leave that running
for just now.
What we do want to do
is import some dashboards. Now I've tried to
make this as easy for other people to
use as well.
So on GET lab,
Rawkode slash get series example.
I have packaged up the dashboards that we're
gonna be using today. InfluxDB
two ships with a component called packager which
allows us to import these dashboards in a
very declarative and Kubernetes fashion. In fact, you'll
actually see that the spec for the manifest
is very much inspired by Kubernetes.
I have copied this file
here.
So now I want to import it. And
we did this with Influx
package
fail,
packager dot yaml.
I will just point it to the host.
I believe this is the default,
never hurts to be explicit.
And we're going to say yes, create those
resources
and hopefully
we have four dashboards available.
Now if I click on this, it should
just break
At least we're not gonna see any data
just yet.
Especially because we haven't set on one hour.
Now the first commit on Docker would have
been what? Sometime in 2013,
'20 '14. So let's just
we have some data.
So we'll zoom out first. Let me
we don't wanna dive into obviously
looking at us on a daily basis over
a span of
seven and a half years.
Maybe not gonna be entirely useful at the
start.
And this is still loading data. We've currently
processed 20,000 commits. So we still got a
little way to go.
So let me explain
the setup. So we set the time period
here. I went back as far as I
feel I need to, which is roughly correct.
The first commit was April 2013.
We have a couple of variables that are
configured for us
and say of the package or template.
So we have this repository one which actually
executes a flux query on our get CD
bucket
and just pulls out all of the unique
repository tag values so that we can dig
into individual repositories without having to hard code
anything.
We also
allow
we also have that window filter. So by
default InfluxDB tries to calculate the window that
makes the most sense based on the density
of the data
within the time range that you specified on
the dashboard.
Now while I trust InfluxDB,
wanna get very specific in a way that
I'm gonna query this data. So I'm actually
just gonna specify a variable called my window
period where I can break things down to
dailies, monthlies, quarterlies, weeklies and yearlies. And we'll
kind of play with them as we take
the dashboards.
So we come back to the overview dashboards.
We're now at 42,000 commits. I think we're
a good chunk of the way through there.
We'll take a look at just one of
these queries to see how we consume those
variables.
Now because variables of InfluxDB two can only
be strings. One of the things I do
need to do when I assume this is
actually cast that string to a duration literal.
So you can just see my aggregate window
cast into a duration and performing an arbitrary
count of the commits over time.
Let's
pop over and
see where we are. We are complete. So
buffer fullness zero.
We imported all of those.
I didn't actually see when it finished but
we scroll up.
47.
In fact, okay. So just finished. So it
did take around three hundred seconds.
Four minutes and six seconds. Perfect.
Now
I have a dilemma.
Now, do I wanna risk importing all of
that Kubernetes data while I'm exploring the Docker
stuff?
Or do we do a little bit of
exploration on the Docker stuff before I kill
InfluxDB?
Let's take a look at Docker first.
Well at least take a look at the
overview dashboard. We'll maybe take a look at
one of the break downs first and then
I'll maybe hopefully feel a bit braver about
doing the Kubernetes import.
So let's refresh this one more time. We
have all the commits. We're breaking down by
quarter
and what we can see here
is the first couple of graphs that we
provide
are just a kind of
a way to understand the commit history.
Now we can see that in the early
days, you know, there's a lot of growth
and Mobi Docker project.
But actually it's
the number of commits is on the decline
ever since 2017.
I'm not sure why that is just yet.
I'm trying to think of major events that
have happened over the last three years.
Obviously, Docker, you know, as a company has
has always failed to find
kind of the path to profitability.
Other container technologies have popped up, you know,
I'm using pod man locally.
It could just be that they broke out
a lot of their
primary repository and to other repositories. I know
they went heavy down the kit route where
they had, you know, Linux kit, they had
VM kit. I don't even know the names
of all the kits, network kits, one kit.
So it it could just be a lot
of that code and a lot of the
effort from the community and by the company
has been pushed out other avenues.
Or it could just be that the company
has maybe been shrinking in size but I
don't really know if that's the case. Hopefully
we can melt slightly stronger
and infinities
as we look at more data. So
Alright. So this is the breakdown
across
multiple repositories.
So obviously, there was only one repository
until
what's this?
First quarter twenty sixteen
when swarm kit
was a thing.
So quite a lot here, in fact that's
an awful lot of commits
in the first six months that could show
just that maybe some of the code was
extracted from the primary repository.
Although I don't think swarm is ever
baked into the docker CLI. I think it
always was slightly separate.
Let's try and maybe come back to work
out what that is later as well.
A little spike and
commits here. What's that? October 2019.
Again, at right now, I'm not really sure
what that spike could be.
But let's see that in FluxDB. So let's
change this window and see if it maybe
gives us a
maybe a little bit more information into what's
actually happening. So if we bring this in
by month, it should yeah. So it's it's
not as smooth anymore because we're not aggregating
as much.
So
I mean this spike still exists definitely around
October 2019. I'm not sure what that is.
There are definitely sharp decline here.
I'll maybe need to do a little Google
and just check what happened to Docker at
the end of twenty sixteen.
I'm not even sure when they raised money.
Normally,
when I analyze open source projects that have
raised money,
you can generally tell where that raise was.
So in fact, why don't we try and
guess that now?
So I'm assuming the first race has to
be just this crazy spike.
Yeah. So let's go with April 2013.
There is
growth here. I'm not sure if it's
I'm not sure if it's funding just because
I would maybe expect to see slightly steeper
curve
but it could be maybe when the project
was open sourced and I'm not sure what
date that was but we can always look
that up too.
I would say that's a definite funding probably
March 2015.
And you can just see here
as the company was really focused on swarm
that there's a massive dip and the effort
to the other contributions
to mobile Docker itself.
And but that does come back up. So
I'm gonna say maybe that was funding
April 2013
and
March.
So we'll go Crunchbase
Docker.
Show me the money.
Okay.
Proceed.
So
January
and September
2014.
So this was a raise but the
peak of that curve is actually
a little bit later than I thought it
would be. A little bit earlier than I
thought it would be. I guess then we
also have a little follow-up peak here. So
definitely the the round was there.
In fact, I looking at the wrong dates?
Yeah. That's the wrong dates.
Oh, wait. I'm just I'm getting everything wrong.
Okay. So we
don't have data from here, so let's ignore
that.
January 14 and September 14.
Alright. So there is spike here
and then there was a raise here. Okay.
So that's more like what I would expect.
If the raise was here,
especially just with that being the Christmas or
holiday period, you know, there would be a
sharp decline and then as January is or
as we're pushing towards the first quarter of
that month, there's been a substantial
increase in contributions.
April and November 15.
Yeah. So,
but yeah. I mean, some of these space
do definitely line up. But that's not that
interesting. That was just a curiosity of anything.
Let's take a look at contributions.
So definitely a decline ever since 2017.
I'm not sure how to explain that.
Total contributors over the years, two and a
half thousand.
Let's break that down. Swarm kept very little
traction. I don't think that's a surprise.
Especially I'm assuming when we pull on the
Kubernetes data here, we're gonna see that
pretty much make this lane indistinguishable.
It's just gonna be flattened right down here
because I'm assuming the Kubernetes one is gonna
be much larger.
But there has been growth. A lot of
growth contributor wise to the Docker and Mobby
project.
But something definitely happened in 2017. I'm not
sure
what that might be.
Yeah. Maybe prod some people and see what
we can find out.
So we're taking a look at commits and
we're taking a look at contributors.
This is now the release information.
So what we can actually see here is
I don't think
Swartcat has really ever had a tag on
this repository.
One
tag in 2016.
But we do see there's a pretty sporadic
but cadence that does exist with Docker itself.
Definitely,
you know,
these kind of inclines early on just show
that the project was young. We've had tagging
releases quite often, pushed them out maybe to
get some feedback.
Definitely a quiet period here.
But just random
random peaks as we go.
And these graphs are the same. These are
just two different ways to kind of visualize
it. We'll just scatter here. We can see
that volatility early on again.
Just when these dots are further away, it
just means there's not a lot of consistency.
There is consistency here
but still,
you know, flooding of activity outside the norm.
And then when you view that as a
histogram, can see there's not a lot of
level across here and
extremely volatile here, a little bit here, not
sure what the deal was there.
Maybe like slightly more consistent towards the end.
Something else gets CD scripts has the ability
to do is just to understand the files
in the repository.
Now because
Docker is pretty much entirely running go,
all we're just gonna see is one big
purple line of go.
We also have the markdown line here.
So
what's that? No documentation that exist these in
this project. At least very little documentation existed
in this project until
the metals at end of twenty fourteen.
And
I mean, that's a little bit worrying, but
there's not been very much documentation or markdown
fails added to the repository.
That could just show that the docs were
extracted to their own repository at the early
twenty eighteen, late '20 '17.
I'm not sure.
I've got some PNGs being added
and some random crappy files that someone probably
didn't mean to commit.
Okay. What do we got down here? We're
just breaking down those file types again by
repository.
Most of the documentation is in the mobi
project.
Go for swarm.
I don't really see a line for markdown
on swarm.
Concerning.
Okay.
Something else that GET series gives us the
ability to do
is
try and get help.
Maybe not so much for an open source
project, I guess.
But if you're working I mean, if you're
doing if you're really gonna use these if
if you were going to use get series
and these dashboards
in your private company or organization,
it could be a good way just to
say how do I get help writing
markdown?
You know, put Rust here just because Rust
is obviously the new shiny that a lot
of people are adopting.
But if I wanna know who the main
contributors to the documentation and I'm making,
I'm guessing that the documentation is the markdown
files.
Marydocker.com.
I'm
assuming she. They have 1,200
commits
of markdown there.
I wanna understand
how to rate good, a go code in
this project.
We've got 7,000 commits from githubigand.nl
and you know, those
top five there are probably the people that
I'd want to go speak to to understand
the go code here.
And what I like doing with this
this table here is also just shows you
some of the random crap that's in the
repository.
So, you know, who committed adult one? Well,
quite a lot of people. I'm gonna assume
that's not an accident then.
.Bsd.Damien,
Fedora's,
you know, who's committing the images.
There's a nice macOS folder. That's always a
pleasure to see. Do we have a DS
store?
No DS store.
AI file. Nice.
Oh, there's something from Sublime or Textmate
depending on when this was.
Lots of random stuff.
Don't think there's anything else particularly interesting at
all. That peril. Nice.
And if you want help with peril, that's
the person we're gonna go chat to.
Okay.
So let's
take a look at our next dashboard of
this.
This is the single repository
kind of a deeper dive.
So hopefully we can find some patterns and
a single repository here.
Now I am running this over a large
window. I'm hoping it's not gonna
take too long.
Okay. So this is the repository
query that we showed at the start.
We're going to take a loop morebie. I'm
assuming that's going to be slightly more interesting
than swarm kit. I'm going to stick with
the periods of a month for the time
being.
Now what this first graph does is
it's still breaking down the commits only this
time we're looking at
the stats on each commit itself. So we
want to understand
how many insertions are aware, how many deletions
and how many files were modified as part
of that commit.
And the files modified should always be dwarfed
by the insertions and deletions here.
But because you know, generally we we write
a lot more code than we do spinning
up new files or touching files etcetera.
What the blue line above the purple line
means is that we're generally writing new code.
Purple line being bigger than the blue generally
means that we're deleting
code and what you would expect to see
is generally these lines will run very close
to each other.
The LP extension is just laying protocol.
I made it up for the sorry, the
question on YouTube. I made it up for
the purpose of this.
It's just a text file and laying protocol
format.
So
the
what what I would normally expect to see
on a
stable repository.
Those lines are tracking each other pretty frequently.
If there are any major deletions that come
generally after some major insertion just kind of
show refactoring or extracting
of code and and kinda cleaning that up.
When the lines are running very very close
together, it just means that only changes are
being made.
I generally consider that a little bit of
a warning sign
because if you're always just changing code, you're
not really driving any new features
and probably just fixing a lot of bugs.
And if we see too much blue over
the purple, it means that we're only writing
new code and that's something I would expect
to see early in a project but not
necessarily later.
But of course it depends on the way
that the team works, way that they handle
new features, etcetera.
Now
we know there was money raised here that
would show this explosion of of new code.
I guess new developers come on to the
team. They're all working on new features.
We see that again here. I can't remember
when the funding was but
you know,
they are definitely focusing on new features for
the first twelve months. Again, that's totally normal
and, you know, major feature expansion here. Then
we've got a period of kind of fixes
another little bit of a feature expansion here,
but then a heavy feature expansion here. A
little bit of cleanup and then we're back
to that kind of modifying code rather investing
in new code. This is probably a little
bit of refactoring here
And then this is what I mean here.
I keep saying here.
These bumps are generally, I like to see
these when I'm analyzing the get history of
a project.
You know, massive amount of new code to
me which show where we write in this
different component and then when we come back
and we had to move something else from
the project. So it could be right. We
just want to extract this out of this
directory where it's maybe coupled with a whole
bunch of other components and we wanna extract
it over here.
There are graphs further down the page where
hopefully we can actually identify what that the
factoring was. So we'll try and come back
to that.
We've got a lot of new development here
followed again by this deletion. This is good.
Again, I think it's just refactor, refactor, refactor.
And of course that's usually healthy after there
has been this kind of feature explosion here.
Not an explosion, it's still there's a bit
of prominence there with the amount of insertions
in the code over deletion.
These I've,
I haven't worked out what these double peaks
really are yet. I mean, it's an awful
lot of deletions, an awful lot of insertions.
It's just one big massive change to the
code base.
Again, let's try and make sure we come
back to what was this? The start of
and this
twenty fifteen July ish. And we'll see if
we can actually, when we do the breakdown
of the directories of the code changed and
try and work out what happened here.
Okay. So moving on to later times, we
don't need to go over all this again.
We see feature driven development, feature driven development,
feature driven development, feature driven development with
little flurries of changes and bug fixes along
the way.
Thanks John for answering that.
Okay.
So total commands mean come up per window
and not very useful. Right? Because we've already
covered that in the overview. We don't need
to go over that again.
The next part of this dash dashboard tries
to give
you a sense of what a
standard commit
looks like in this repository.
So we break it down by quantiles. We
have the ninetieth quantile, the fiftieth quantile and
the first quantile.
So you should rarely
have a commit this size, rarely have a
commit this size. Most of your commits should
be in this ballpark.
Leading up to this one but hopefully not
too close.
So the average commit across the Mobi project,
again, we're looking at a very large time
period right now. So the stats are gonna
be somewhat skewed.
If we break this down to three months,
which I'll do
say five minutes,
we'll see our actual true representation of what
standard commit looks like now and we could
probably run that against the first twelve months
and I would actually expect those numbers to
be substantially different.
Lame protocol.
Yeah. Sorry about the accent. I'll work on
it.
Okay. So
standard commit across the lifetime of this project
is you modify one file, delete four lines
and insert 11.
Pushing up towards a 42 insertions, 70 deletions
and modifying eight files.
In fact, you know what, let's just break
this down now. What does it look like
in 2020? If I was coming to this
project now,
we can see that the standard commit,
you would modify two files, four deletions, six
insertions and while the 90% tail is is
huge.
So I mean,
probably being some chunky refit. Okay. Commencementary factoring
in the last
six months.
I'm not sure maybe that has something to
do with the sale to Midrandes.
Maybe they were starting to extract a lot
of quota at Moby.
I don't know. Maybe I would see that
more in SwanKit. I don't know.
Let's compare that to the
feature days.
2015.
So we just wanted to break that down
to that year.
Okay. The actual
consistency across the years probably quite telling and
quite a mature development team, you know, this
kind of commit mean if you will of
modifying one or two files, you know, making
anywhere from five to 20 changes.
To me just shows
that's a good indicator. I don't like to
see that number get too high. That's for
sure.
Okay.
Let's jump back over to our
massive view of the world. Just give that
a second
and we'll scroll down.
So there's this release cadence. We've seen that
new review. We're not gonna look at it
here. We have a table that's just gonna
show us all of those releases.
What we can see here is just the
pattern, the name for releasing, you know, was
that always the case?
No,
they used to do semantic versioning
and that changed
in 2017.
So the conversion is nineteen o three. In
fact, there's not been a release since November.
Make of that what you will.
Okay. So what about the offers
as they've
come and go over time?
So we can see some crazy crazy
peaks at the start. So there's Solomon,
I believe was one of the founders. He
was the CTO at the start
who committed a lot of codes
in the early days
and dropped
stopped training code in 2015. I'm assuming
as a CTO,
focusing more on growing the company, the vision,
leadership management and all of those things. So
obviously as
priorities, we're just changing around that time.
What we do see here,
a lot of activity for a very short
period of time.
So maybe an early employee dot clouds
moved on in 2014,
hasn't committed since.
We've got Victor here.
Interesting.
So, you know,
definitely a prominent developer from 2013 to 2015.
Guess maybe and so
many random hypotheses just coming out now, but
maybe took a leadership or management position
in 2015.
I mean, as an early developer on the
product, of course, as a company grows, it's
gonna be, you know, maybe pushed into a
position of leadership and management. Maybe it doesn't
like it lasted a couple of years, went
back to being a developer,
made me moved on from the company in
2018.
Complete speculation.
But we could see that, you know, very
prominent early on,
depth in the middle spike.
Not sure what that was, but again, it's
around that 2017
period where we did see some
weirdness on the commit total graph. So I'm
not sure what happened there.
We can also see we've got
more people.
Let's see. Is there anyone?
Michael Crosby is still definitely one of the
early employees still at the company today.
Nice
kind of depth for a few years and
then a little spike at the end. Not
sure what that means.
Who else we got?
We got Jesse Frizelle,
Alexander,
David Calaveras.
Not sure why I know that name.
Rings a bell.
Prominent committer for a year.
There's probably the person,
I mean, highly speculative based on their commit
history but maybe the project leads since 2016
just with
the amount of commit scenario. Maybe they could
maybe the lead wouldn't be committed as much
as that but definitely someone who's driving the
mobi project forward.
And then we've got other people. So and
there's a lot of density around the bottom
and that's a good sign for an open
source project. It just means we've got a
lot of people that are getting and then,
you know, commits in our spare time and
maybe it's not their full time job
or just, you know, trying to contribute to
the project as much as possible.
And these numbers on the Y axis are
quite large,
you know, so that's, you know, these people
are getting hundreds of commits. That's a lot
of commits on a monthly basis.
You know, even down to here over at
the start in '40, these are still substantial
committers to the project.
Just kind of dwarfed by some of the
more prominent people on the project.
Okay.
This big blue line is always my, my
favorite. So what do we see here? Well,
what I've tried to do with GET series
is actually
process
all of the commit messages.
And what I'm looking for is something that
represents a semantic or conventional commit.
So if you're not familiar with that.
It's
a specification
that says, you know, if you write your
commits in this format, you're gonna be able
to deliver some intent or meaning behind your
commit because we're all, I mean,
okay. I can always be for myself. As
a developer, it very easy for me just
to say effects, change stuff,
you know, new feature, whatever. And
that doesn't mean a lot
especially to a computer
but
even to other developers sometime we're lacking a
lot of context into why we're actually doing
something. So this is a specification where we
prefix all of our commits with fix, feat,
chore, refactor, test.
We then give a scope which part of
the component where which part of the project
or the components was I modifying
and then a description of that change. So
just by, you know, having this format to
adopt, it generally makes me at least,
you know, put in better messages.
But because
at least that the Docker project has never
adopted us as a standard which is what
we see with these big massive blue lines.
So what I'm gonna do is just
zoom
and like this.
And we can see
some people are doing it. So we've got
managed to pick up a type of windows
so there's a lot of
prefix on commit messages of windows cool on
by the looks of it.
The daemon has been tagged as the type.
We're not really getting the information I would
like to see here from this, which means
I'm not gonna get the same information that
I want in this next bay either,
which is where we try and work out
which component they're actually modifying.
But I do have a backup plan. So
don't worry about that.
Okay.
So when we ignore the nones
again, we're just not getting an idea here
because
that format was never adopted by project.
Now, because we're
making good progress with this dashboard,
I'm gonna risk it and put it on
Kubernetes now. So I should drop that and
we'll pull out more, but we don't need
it to reprocess that.
We'll fire up teller f again.
Okay.
That's running.
So,
we do have a plan getting past the
components and the conventional commits.
So where are my dashboards?
Okay. So we'll come back to the, these
table helpers in a minute.
What I'm more interested in right now
is a directory breakdown.
So
although the commit messages themselves cannot be processed,
I still can work out which directories the
commits are modifying.
Maybe it was a bit quick to start
running this Kubernetes thing because my dashboards are
going a little bit slow.
We'll give this a few seconds.
I may
either narrow the window or pause the telegraph
import. I'm not sure yet.
Decisions.
Oh.
Alright. Let's see. What are we doing? Buffer
filling us why it's here. So one ninety
three. So the buffer is still gonna out.
We're still processing that lane protocol.
We are writing a substantial amount of metrics
but the fact that the buffer is going
up means
I'm not really past the worst of it.
So decision,
make a decision.
Definitely broken that window now.
Alright. Let's narrow this down just for
a few minutes.
See if we can get an update to
start looking at those directory breakdowns before
I
make a decision to stop the Kubernetes import.
So I'm hoping that just by dropping this
time period down to the last kind of,
you know, eighteen months
and
the dashboards at the bottom will will load
and then we'll come back and do the
seven and a half year analysis.
Let's go. Where is directories?
There we go.
Let's try giving that a few seconds again.
Also doesn't help that I have quite a
lot of graphs on this board that are
all
fetching,
you know, a sizable amount of data.
It may have made sense to me if
we break this up for cloud larger
repositories.
And we can see that this number is
is still climbing.
It's a big commit. A big yesterday.
I got too confident.
Number's still up.
How big was it? It was
I said 40,000,000.
Mental note to self. Use a a code
VM next time
instead of my laptop.
So back to the 5,000,000,
six million in the queue.
40,000,000
total.
I can't attempt to just let yeah. Let's
let it run. And I have some graphs
there so at least I can talk about
something instead of mumbling to myself.
Okay.
So we're let's use the eighteen month. We'll
we'll come back to the seven year but
this
when a project doesn't or didn't implement conventional
commits very early, it can be difficult to
understand what was actually being worked on.
So another thing that GET series does is
it puts enough tagging
on the commits that it stores in Influx
that we can see just what directories the
changes were happening in.
So
we see here are some spikes.
So let's just test it.
Now we've got Kubernetes in here. Oh, wait.
That's probably why that was so slow.
Alright.
Let's jump back to Moby.
My pure computer.
Come on, take pad. You got this.
Maybe.
7,000,000
there.
We got some dodgy commits that can't be
parsed.
Yeah. I don't think I've got enough escaping
on some of the actual
when we process the the line of code
that changed within the the deltas.
There are some things I don't think I'm
checking for and escaping for. So, you know,
I need to go back and deal with
that.
Okay.
That's docker. This is docker. Right. So eighteen
months of the mobi project so we can
see a lot of work happened on the
integration
CLI here. No idea what that is.
Projects
commit surrender directory.
That's gonna make analysis about the pain in
the ass to be honest.
We can see, you know, go projects love
to keep as much code as possible in
the root directory. So generally I, you know,
seen a dot here.
You just get kinda used to it with
gold projects.
You can see he's been working the daemon.
We've got more vendor crap.
Let's just try and fill out some of
these top ones because I think they're skewing
our look at what's happening.
Woah. Okay.
What we got here is that's demonvendor.integrations
to you like.
I mean, the vendor stuff just makes it
really difficult to see where where effort is
and actually it's probably gonna skew most of
the stats.
That's disappointing.
So we can see some commits to the
API.
The HTTP,
you tell the API,
Docker file, the client. We can still see
where the effort is going
even though it's a little bit more difficult
in this project. And I can I can
keep trying to zoom in to pull out
more stuff, but
the daemon container
builder
pack? So we we can see where some
of the effort is, but I think
that vendor folder has kind of
causing a bit of a a haze over
what's happening.
Okay. What else do we have here?
We can just see the goal. I don't
know what the dot none is. I got
cop. So I mean, as a goal project,
this is what I would expect.
Alright. Something else we try to do with
get series is provide more helper of things.
Now we already kinda seen the
we already seen the fail extension one
on the overview dashboard.
Something else we tried to do is using
conventional commits. Let's try to pull out as
many of those components as possible. So if
you want to say,
get help with the daemon
and
let's say, okay, package control daemon. If I
wanna go speak to someone,
I wanna understand how to make changes to
this daemon. I now know who to go
and speak to, you know, these are the
people that have committed to this directory.
I wonder if that's
I
don't know this is reloaded properly.
Yeah. If I type stateful set or maybe
that's query is wrong.
Let's check.
It should be okay.
It's just I think everything's just
fallen to PCs with this import.
On the plus side, the buffer fullness
is dropping.
Should be back in business then soon.
So
let's try
something that definitely only gonna be in docker.
Let's think. Swarm.
Okay. So we could see a swarm Ritter.
Miranda's popping up because that's not a surprise.
Let me see some people here. So I
mean,
the TLDR here is these tables are really
really good way.
Not just, you know, you know, our IDEs
do support some level of introspection here where
we can see who modified that line last
or who was the last commit in this
file. We can do a GET log on
an individual file and get names but I
think this is just so much more valuable
in the fact that we can filter on
any directory
and we can see the commit counts as
well. We know who the prominent committers are
versus the people that probably can manifest a
typo.
So
this is a really good way to navigate
your code especially, you know, joining new companies
or looking at new open source projects and
trying to work out, right, how can I
get help for something I wanna do here?
We also have the concept of co owners
where we do the get series analysis. I've
seen that dot Derek.YAML
here. It's no surprise that Alex Elsie's name
is next to that. So could see is
the
founder and I think maintainer of the Derek
bot project.
We can also maybe just filter on
the
something specific within Docker. Let's
try this. Must be a secret fail of
some kind.
So see,
want to understand
vendor directory is gonna read
everything.
Just pick a random file.
Maybe I wanna improve the testing or integration
containers and the secret namespace stuff.
I'm assuming just say words that's in that
file name and that'll make sense. Right? And
what we can see is there's a few
people here I could go reach out to.
So the concept of a co owner would
just be who
again, who is the most prominent committer to
this file.
Something else that gets you this will try
and do for you is just give you
a table of every commit within the window.
So, you know, I am looking at eighteen
months right now but we can just scroll
through all these commits. If I click on
one, I see the author when it happened
and I can just copy that getcha. So
another if semantic commits were a thing, I'd
be able to break these commits down by
the component or features or effects and just
see the all the features that were released
in the last thirty days, all the fixes
that were released in the last thirty days,
all the defectoring and so forth. A nice
way to take a look at project
really painful over large windows. In fact if
I ran this across the seven and a
half years,
you know, it'd probably drag a little bit
but you know, I am running beta version
of the software so we have to
give it a little affordances.
Something else we try and graph is just
looking at files that are new within the
project. So that seems really good as a
way to understand any migration paths within the
project. Like if something I I see when
I analyzed the InfluxDB repositories was that I
could actually visualize through the graphing the transition
from JavaScript to TypeScript.
Analyzing the Mobi project, I'm not going to
see anything like that because it's just all
go mostly.
And then other ways to visualize that are
just a scar plot. What directories are changing?
What type of file extensions are changing?
We can also see deletions over time. So
you know, when you write enough go, you're
gonna be deleting enough go. You can see
PB files being deleted here. I'm sure what
those are. Some JSON files being deleted
and that dot none which has been a
regular pop up here. I'm not sure what
that is.
Something else that you use to kind of
understand how healthy a project is is always
by its documentation.
So
what I can't give you is a magic
number that you should have you know, one
line of documentation for every 10 lines of
real code.
But you can just you can always you'll
have a good understanding of your projects you're
contributing to or maintaining of whether you have
enough documentation. And if not, you wanna be
getting this purple line moving closer to the
blue. So the blue is just how many
lines of code were inserted within this window.
Like if we use this as an example,
there's five
five point three thousand lines of code that
were not comment markers versus the 1,200 lines
of code that does have a common marker.
Which is pretty good ratio.
You know, five to one. That's
I would definitely take that. Most some of
the open source projects I have analyzed, you
know, it's been closer to 20.
You know, one line of one line of
comment where every 20 lines are code and
that's always been slightly concerning.
And if we wanna just break down those
comments by the fail extensions, we can see
that the majority of all of the all
of the comments are in go code and
very little and anything else. There is a
bit of a bugging get series and that
markdown fails always show as comment because they
have headers on them. So yeah.
It
does the best it can.
Did I skip anything else when I was
running through this dashboard? No. That's disappointing. There's
no conventional
commits. We did get a look at the
directories over some window.
Still flushing.
But it would've been nice to see a
bit more there.
So projects that adopt conventional commits are gonna
get a lot more value by taking a
look at this.
Now the year on your analysis repository
dashboard
even
gives us a way to just kinda
look at the lifetime of the project
comparing year after year.
I don't think I've really got this dashboard
great yet.
Disclaimer.
But you can
try and pick up a few patterns. So
we don't wanna look at Kubernetes.
And what I'm gonna do is just do
quarters
and we'll do Mobi.
Give us a second.
So even though the time period here is
one year, the 01/01/2019
to 01/01/2020,
it's actually just pulling out all data.
I think it does like a twenty year
scan.
But then aligns the time windows so that
we actually see each year here starts
here and ends here and we can see
where the the peaks are. So we can
see that as far as releases go, 2015
was a huge year for Docker or the
mobile project.
And then we can kinda see there as
obviously some of it, a little bit of
a release cadence here between the two purple.
So what's that? 2017 and 2018, you know,
pretty strong cadence lines are together.
And then a little bit variable for other
years. With regards to commit counts, we can
see their best year probably was
that's 2015.
Yeah. 2015
or
with 2019
being pretty much the lowest year in terms
of commits ever.
Slightly concerning. I don't think Docker is in
particularly great shape with those. Just looking at
those graphs and we've seen that earlier too.
These dashboards
can be
kind of useful if you know the people
and you wanna understand
who's contributing what to your project. But what
we can see here is that, you know,
the most substantial year
gauging it by the number of commits, which
is of course not no way to measure
productivity of a developer. But we can see
that, you know, 2013,
Julian has
a a
substantial amount of commits. It's the highest over
any other year per single contributor.
Michael Crosby in 2014
to 2015.
What I've got? I've got Solomon in 2013
and,
you know, taken over for 2019
and 2020. We've Sebastian.
You can just kind of highlight
who the driving force behind the project is.
And again, if we had the conventional commits,
this these two would be fantastic too. And
that we'd be able to understand,
you know, how does 2019 compared to 2017
and '20 '16 or 2018 with regards to
how much features we've delivered versus how many
bugs we fixed. So
because we don't have that data with the
Docker project, these graphs
don't drive a lot of particular use.
And this wall of shame, I really need
to rename that. It's such a dreadful name.
It's basically just a random one where I
had like an idea
of things I would try and
delete leaderboard style stuff.
The challenge for the leaderboard stuff is the
queries are super slow.
So
let's
check if telegraph is finished first.
So we got 1,000,000 to go.
Okay.
Let's take a look at the last year
first. Shouldn't be too painful.
And then maybe we'll try and widen that
as the Kubernetes stuff finishes.
Alright. So what this does as it tries
to calculate
the
Prower robot.
So that doesn't do a selector on repository,
but we should add that, shouldn't we?
So let's modify
That's crazy.
We're gonna say
where repository
I know computer.
I'm beating you pretty hard.
We'll just copy this. We'll add this to
all the dashboards here.
And go.
I didn't submit at first, but I'm hoping
the query should be okay. We're gonna check
this off Kubernetes.
And we're gonna modify
these ones here.
So just making sure that they're all using
the repository filter.
And the reason the repository filter wasn't on
this is I was running it against all
of InfluxDB's
repositories and that was actually kinda useful to
have a global view, but just because I'm
doing a couple of open source ones here,
really doesn't make a lot of sense.
Okay. So
so this first one just kinda works out
the highest number of commits per person per
month and then shows us the most the
the months
or just some by the month of commits.
So you can see, you know, we already
saw from previous graphs that Sebastian from the
last eighteen months has really been the driving
force behind the the mobile project.
Has
again, don't just commit to this in a
productivity, but in March 2019, you know, hammered
at 375
commits. That's that's more than 10 commits to
master a day.
I mean, that's substantial.
Come on computer.
Not long to go. I'll give you a
break.
I mean,
these queries are are particularly rough especially when
it's a holiday in the mean days coding
one because they are doing aggregates across
days.
The mean days coding analyses every
groups all the commits by day per author
and then tries to give you an arbitrary
number like you know, if you were to
work on this project how many days would
you how many days per
month would you contribute?
Would you spend contributing code to the master
branch?
So it's usually the higher that number generally
shows the maturity of the project because
pull requests are being handled
relatively quickly.
The CICD means that those those changes are
I've got a level of confidence. There's good
testing.
It just means that, you know, that cycle
time from creating a branch pushing the first
line of code to the branch is really
really important.
Maybe more so.
And if you know, private organizations with private
repositories than an open source, open source can
have a certain of affordance of moving a
little bit slower.
Okay. Let's see what's going on with telegraph
here. Because we still want to be able
to run at least get the quick look
at Kubernetes before we finish up.
I just realized I wonder if the
load my machine is under has maybe caused
any problems with the stream. Although I don't
think I've had any comments to suggest that,
but
computer.
I mean, I can't even get focus on
my terminal.
Okay. So at least you can hear me
but
what we have now is my
computer seems to have completely locked up. I
cannot focus on my terminal to kill telegraph.
Visual Studio Code
is trying to display an error message and
failing miserably.
Yeah.
It's just locked up.
Pretty bad.
So I don't know whether to
damn.
My browser is unresponsive.
Telegraph.
Oh, I've got focus, can I kill it?
I've lost my mouse.
Alright. I have typed kill all telegraph.
Let's see if I can oh, I spelled
telegraph wrong. Kill
all.
Let's see if I can just get it
killed.
It's getting a bit more responsive.
Is it dead?
Don't kill pad one.
Okay. That's it. Alright. Good. Wow.
Alright. So what happens?
I don't know how it stops. I have
to up.
It's load spaced to 35
on my
eight core machine. Nice.
Ram usage
on Influx is set at 50%,
but
I'm responsive.
Code deaf not crashed. We can open that
again.
And I'll just hopefully tape that back.
Okay.
Let's just make sure.
Alright. Well, Influx is still running.
It's over lining here.
That's real load this dashboard.
That's a bit better.
So this this table here tries to kind
of tell you how many days or how
many days of the month you'll be pushing
code to the master branch. For an open
source project, know,
being around
eight days,
it's it's pretty good.
I'm analyzing more be here. This could also
just be an indicator.
I mean,
this may be
much more of a
commitment
by the company rather than open source contributions.
Just because these numbers are higher than I
would expect for an open source project, which
means that probably a substantial amount of the
committers are employed by Docker rather than open
source. But that's obviously a little bit of
speculation at the moment.
Okay. So before we finish,
let's come back into the overview.
In fact, now let's just go straight into
the single repo. Let's see how much of
Kubernetes we got.
And I think I'll I'll what I'll do
is I'll do my
own session with Kubernetes with a chunky VM
just to ensure we have no issues.
But I still wanna see if we can
take a look at it just now.
Okay. So I can see that we processed
55,000
commits
of 92,000.
Now,
doesn't tell me
how much of the deltas we processed.
Maybe we'll get a little bit of an
indication of that as we go through this
dashboard. So let's just do that and see
what happens. So we can get a seed
inception of Kubernetes seems to be around the
2015 mark.
I think that's right. I don't think we're
missing too.
I don't think we're missing too much of
the commits from here.
May just be later commits. So
I think what I like about this graph
here from the Kubernetes perspective
Okay. So we've got deletions and a
kind of red color insertions and purple now
rather than the blue from earlier
is that we do see
A lot of features being driven, you know,
the insertions.
Higher for the entire what? First year and
a half fat.
Insertions are just consistently hired, aren't they? This
is always right in your code, new code,
a little bit of deletions here, but there
are still a strong,
strong sense of changes and deletions throughout.
Let's see what we can work out down
here.
With regards to what our average commit looks
like in this repository,
two files, 15 insertions,
slightly larger case up to 300. So again,
just to say in the commits are generally
focused, they're not too large, you know, there
are some projects you realize where, you know,
the
main commit can be, you know, 300 lines
or or thousand lines of code.
Just
shows that obviously
they've had a strong sense of how to
build this product out from the start. We
see a pretty good release cadence moving forward.
I mean, there are some spikes but you
know, those could be patch releases.
We see betas here and the various things
and stuff.
Let's just see if we can get some
more interesting stuff. I wonder how much of
the offer information we have available to us.
Not much hope for the semantic commits. This
big blue line again.
Okay. So we've got the Kubernetes merge robot
and we've got this to make here,
CI robot and proud robot. So normally
if I wanted to in fact, when
I do a deeper analysis of this repository,
we have this one session
with a nice big shiny machine.
You know, we'll filter this stuff out. What
we actually wanna be able to see is
just let's just drag this
as the people behind this project. So
let's see. Here we go.
We got Brandon Barnes,
also one of the founders of the project,
not committing so much anymore.
Got Brian Grant.
What about
it's just a little box.
We've
got add in with a spike here.
Doctor Stefan.
Yeah. I mean, I think anyone who's familiar
with the Kubernetes project knows Jordan's name. You
can see, you know, we've been committed to
this project substantially from start to finish.
And then we can obviously, you know, if
we wanted to zoom in again, we can
try and get into these little lines down
here, but, you know, you can definitely identify
some of the key people in the project
as well as the
patches, double click and reset us, you know,
we can see the project. It's always had
a really strong sense of automation.
We can actually see the death of the
Kubernetes merge bot when it got replaced by
the Kubernetes submit queue.
We've got a CI bot popping up here,
very short lived experiment
and then pro
active in a project for the last eighteen
months. So we can actually see the evolution
of the automation on this project.
I'm not familiar with the Kubernetes merger robot.
But we we can see that, you know,
it's definitely
not in use anymore.
The submit queue I'm actually not even familiar
with either. I think when I do my
deeper dive on a threefold we'll try and
get someone
one of the early after matters of Frequency,
maybe Jordan will join us and we can
just give us a bit of history and
background on what these automation projects were.
The CIO bot definitely a short lived experiment
and I'm proud
is what's been used today.
With regards to the semantic minutes, we've got
a whole load of nuns.
Not holding up much hope for zoom but
let's just
no.
It's all too close together.
Let's
try here to do what we got.
Kubernetes component useful.
GitHub component useful.
Nope.
Yeah. We're not gonna get any information
from the commit patterns,
But we do have the directory breakdown. So
let's see what we see there.
Okay. That's just
noise.
Kubernetes
project. As far as extensions go,
it's pretty much just gonna be exclusively go
again. There's not gonna be really exciting or
interesting here.
Let's just give this a moment.
Okay.
Any rust?
No. But we have restructured text. Wow.
Not a lot though. What else? What else
could we look for? Any peril in this
project? We do have peril.
Jordan.
Okay.
PHP. Oh, wow. We have a PHP commit.
Maybe a little bit of PHP in here.
I'm not sure what that is. We could
always dig into it and find out if
we were genuinely curious.
Do we have a DS store? We do
not dress.
I don't know why I enjoy finding a
DS store. It just
keeps me happy.
Computer locked up again.
We will make it through this dashboard.
We will
okay. We're back.
So components
because this component is a directory breakdown rather
than a semantic commit.
We should be able to understand
some of the aspects here.
In fact, I may just because my computer
is struggling again, drop the time period down.
When my computer lets me do that, obviously.
And what we'll do is we'll maybe just
try and take a twelve month look at
Kubernetes and see what's actively being worked on
just now or maybe even the last three
you know. We can just get a get
a feel for what's happened or what's changed
in the last few releases.
So let's do 2019
or 06/2001.
Let's just take a look at twelve months.
It should be three or four releases depending
on how we hit them.
And, you know what, I'm just gonna do
a hard refresh on this.
So in the last twelve months,
if it's 7,000 commits, 500 per month.
Definitely a lot of features
added at the end of last year.
And the releases since then
have mostly been
changes and bug fixes. I would speculate based
on graph. Now I actually know because I
was the comms lead on the
the
'1 '17 release
that this release here was actually just a
triage bug fixe, make things better release.
The chillest release I believe the title was.
Alright.
So let's come back down here.
Right. Hopefully, it should be a lot faster
now.
Surprised that it loaded to commit a lot
faster than these two, but
k. So component wise,
let's just maybe scroll and see what we
have. It shouldn't be we've got that vendor
directory.
Go projects are always the worst to analyze.
Let's try
to stateful set. So, you know, there's a
stateful set controller.
We can see, you know, the commits over
the last year has not been a lot
of activity there.
But we do know who to go speak
to if we wanted have coders. We don't
need to look at that again. That was
pretty much the same. I'm more interested
in the directory breakdown.
That's going to give me the overview. Those
tables are really good for when I have
specific questions.
If you don't know the question yet, then
the directory breakdown and these graphs are actually
a bit more interesting.
So we can just see, guys, I'll go
code.
We've got none, no extensions.
PB, protobus.
Yep. Not surprised to see that. We've got
some shell scripts going on with regards to
directories. We can see staging test data here.
Test
data. You know, we didn't see a lot
of
insertions. So, you know, the fact that what
we're seeing is is test stuff
to show I guess shows how much testing
goes on in this project and that could
just be if we zoom in, we can
hopefully get
slightly better look so we can see some
framework plugins on the scheduler. We can see
RPMs were there change log.
And then we've got some of the components.
We've got the open API spec. So we
can see what's been worked on, but it's
very difficult on a project of this size.
I think what I need to do when
we do it, we've been even deeper dive
into the Kubernetes project is just
provide a means of filtering out the vendor
directory for sure. I think that's definitely gonna
increase our visibility into this.
New code. I mean, not surprised to see
gold there. It's a gold project.
And we could see the comments if we
want to wait for that. We can see
which files have been deleted by directory and
so forth. So
I think I put my computer
through enough.
Yeah. Let's call it quits there.
Well, I can still actually I think I'm
still going. Yeah. Okay. Cool.